oh hell no he did not just text me he
working late that [ __ ] it's week working
late my ass if you don't walk through
that door to miss half an hour he means
when I can come home tonight because I'm
not gonna be there waiting for his
cheating we'll be there waiting because
but you don't have to put up with a lot
of [ __ ] from me oh and if he think he
gonna do this [ __ ] he is sorely mistaken
oh my man just one chance one and then
after that he'd get one more okay and
then after that he gonna get three
strikes my man was messing around on me
he better get his faraway minute as he
possibly can because he do not want to
get what I'm gonna give to him okay I've
got my [ __ ] real estate license
oh but if and when he does that's fine
okay cuz he can go out and get all turnt
up with these little side hos and
whatnot cuz you're no word [ __ ] he
always gonna come off alright okay I'm
the queen bee and he always don't come
home I'll tell you what happened to be
do come home I ain't gonna be pulling
any that [ __ ] in my house okay house if
he wants to but he ain't never gonna do
that when I'm home
alright you know what even if I'm home
you know I'm talking about okay cuz I
don't give a good goddamn okay that's
what I'm talking about hang on being
that [ __ ] into my bedroom I'll tell you
that much right now
cuz ain't no trifling-ass [ __ ] gonna
wake me up while he's cheating on me in
my bed again okay I told him I looked at
right in the face I said this is the
fifth time I coulda said it better
myself go you right oh you just best
spouting words of wisdom all evening I
ain't listening to a thing then you say
I don't even know what the hell I was
thinking
very good right the second that that man
walks through that door I'm gonna dump
his ass oh okay okay Oh oh my gosh
speak of the devil
[Music]
oh okay
you